everybody knows somebody who searches
health-related information online well
there's actually a name for us and it's
called cyberchondria cyberchondria is
defined as anxiety induced by escalation
during online search to review morbid or
serious content so what does this mean
well it means that you have a headache
and you end up reading about brain tumor
and there's a very good reason behind us
humans have a propensity to escalate to
review the worst possible scenario
probably to dismiss it so come back to
the headache if you went to your doctor
and you said I've a terrible headache
and your doctor said well you could have
anything from a hangover to a brain
tumor you would say oh my goodness
talk to me about the brain tumor and
essentially that's what happens online
people click on the worst case scenario
and therefore those scenarios get driven
up the ranking search rankings so the
point about search it's based on a
frequency model things that are
frequently clicked are those things that
actually rise to the top of search
results that's fine if you're looking at
best beach in Florida but when it comes
to health related matters it's
problematic why because it causes
anxiety and you could be perfectly well
but end up with a nasty case of health
anxiety as a result of search so the
thing is if there's something wrong with
your car and you google us or search it
inherently you're not going to do any
damage to the car but in terms of bodily
symptoms the very act of searching can
bring about or instigate psychosomatic
factors sigh keep in mind
and so mopping body so you can believe
to feel that you were actually suffering
from some terrible condition if you put
any body parts now into search what you
will see is pages of tumor and cancer
and in fact just a month or so ago on
Google's official blog they have well
owned up to the issue and have also told
us that 1% of all an online search
actually relates to medical search
people googling symptoms I've published
in this area and I published a paper
which actually looks at a phenomenon
which I named as cyberchondria by proxy
and that is people searching health
results of others and the thing is if
you survive the initial search and you
get to the intuitive diagnostic websites
that prompt some tautology it actually
can make the problem worse why you've
got a pain in your arm could be from
carrying a heavy bag or a harsh workout
in the gym you go online and you're led
through this decision pathway is the
pain radiating across your chest well
could be do you feel tingling in your
fingertips well when I think about as I
do or you palpate out palpitating well
of course I am you then rush to your GP
your doctor and you present with a
cluster of symptoms that actually mimic
a cardiac event the point is that
doctors don't prompt symptoms but
artificial intelligence based systems
diagnostic tools do there's a great
paper called hypochondriacal immune
ethics and the paper argues that the
doctor-patient relationship is a
hypochondriacal exercise in its own
right one person sitting there talking
about symptoms and the other trying to
interpret them and effectively if you
pair appear from manifest with this
perfect cluster your doctor has got no
choice but to between the pipeline for
intrusive diagnostic investigative
procedures which are all inherently
risky a report came out recently that
was published in the BMJ that has stasis
that iatrogenic death is the third cause
of death in the USA iatrogenic is is
would cover it's a catch-all for
problems in terms of taking medication
medical error infection so its death by
accident within the medical system but
in my book I note and of course I'm
aware of causation correlation but
there's a very interesting trend that
iatrogenic death has increased fourfold
between 1999 and 2011 and actually
shadows the growth of the internet let's
think about that
you